my name is Dylan BT and the first
computer I ever had
of
one of these this was the Amstrad six
one to eight it was 1985 I was 7 years
old my dad brought one of these home and
he put it in the spare room in our house
this was not a very good computer and it
was all right for 1985 it had a green
screen
it came with a couple of very very dodgy
games like a chess game that I could
beat even though I was seven and a game
where you had to throw soap at ghosts
sued invaded a launderette but it also
came with a thing called logoed has
anyone used logo the programming
language and logo was brilliant because
I could use logo to make the computer
draw pictures and it seems weird now
like you know 1 2019 you wanna see
something on a screen it's easy you get
your phone out and you type in anything
you want and there'll be pictures and
video of that online that you can just
download and play and share with people
but back then just getting something on
a screen that wasn't there before was a
big deal you know you've got this 7
years old I was digging through these
programmers manuals and the logo
programming manual was not written for
seven year olds so I would be sat there
working out with all these words mean
and trying things out and when I made
the computer do what I wanted and draw
this picture I got this rush this thrill
it was brilliant and that's never gone
away for me and I hope for many of you
as well that that thrill that you get
when you make the Machine do what you
want like we failed to do with the a/v
there for about 10 minutes now over the
next three days you're gonna see some
amazing talks by some brilliant speakers
about architecture and unit testing and
user interface and experience design
things that are important and useful and
lucrative if you can sell them to the
right people that helped to make
software better in terms of as a tool
for the world we live in
but I'm not gonna talk to you about that
I want to talk to you about something
that I think is important but maybe not
as useful as the other things I wanna
talk to you about art now there is this
famous quote from Oscar Wilde he said
all art is quite useless and maybe it is
maybe all of you being here is a total
waste of your time and everything I'm
going to tell you is pointless and you
should have gone to another talk
or maybe Oscar Wilde was wrong I like
this quote the function of art is to
hold a mirror up to nature art can help
us understand the world that we live in
better and if we want to hold a mirror
up to nature before we can do that we
have to invent the mirror and that's
where science and technology come in
because for hundreds of years we've used
science and technology and tools to see
the world around us in different ways we
had no idea until we invented
microscopes that there was this amazing
microscopic world hidden right
underneath our noses things like this
which is the eyelid of a beetle at 200
times magnification this is crystals
growing in a dish of soy sauce this is
the vessels inside the stem of a banana
leaf this amazing beauty we had never
ever seen until we built the tools to
allow us to see it and we've sent
telescopes and satellites into outer
space we've looked back at our planet
rising over the surface of the Moon
we've looked back from beyond the rings
of Saturn and seen our pale blue dot
down here in the distance we've even
looked into the farthest corners of the
galaxy these are the pillars of creation
they're seven thousand light years away
and we put a telescope in space that
took a photograph of them and sent it
back to us and thanks to modern
computers we have been able to start
exploring another secret world that's
hidden right here under our noses it's a
world of information and mathematics
throughout the 1970s a guy called Martin
Gardner had a monthly column in
Scientific American magazine where he'd
share mathematical puzzles and
curiosities and games with all of his
readers
of all the columns that he published the
one that had the greatest impact was
from october 1970 where he described
something called John Conway's Game of
Life now the game of life as games go it
is not much of a game it is a game for
one player played on an infinite board
and it has only three rules the first
rule of the game of life each of these
little rectangular cells can live it can
die it can be born again if a cell has
zero or one neighbors it dies of
loneliness ah if a cell has two or three
neighbors it survives into the next
generation and if a cell has four or
more neighbors it will die of
overcrowding it's a bit like living in
London and finally the slightly weird
spooky bit if a cell has exactly three
neighbors it will come back to life and
that's it that is the entire rules of
Conway's Game of Life
now when Martin Gardner's column was
first published he included this diagram
here he says these are the life
histories of the five tetrominoes so
these these shapes here
you probably recognize those if you've
ever played Tetris and what he's doing
is he's plotting out how those shapes
evolve over a couple of generations but
looking at it like this on paper is like
gonna a museum and looking at the
butterflies pinned up in the glass case
you can kind of see what they are but
you have no idea what that like you
don't get any sense of the nature of the
the evolution of the game of life so
those five tetrominoes let's see what
they actually do watch this and so from
those five shapes and those three rules
we get this four of them stabilized but
one of them goes into this infinite
looping repeating pattern that we call
traffic lights and you can understand
that using graph paper but instead you
start running the stuff on software you
don't really understand you can't
visualize what's really going on here
even back in the earliest days of doing
the stuff on on graph paper people
started identifying some configurations
which were interesting for all kinds of
reasons one of the earliest
configurations they found was found by a
guy called Bill Gosper in the early 70s
and it's something called a glider and
the glider is a little shape that just
crawls across the grid as it goes every
five or six generations it repeats
itself one squared down and left and
these things keep gliding across this
infinite grid of mathematical space and
people started asking questions like
will other configurations in the game of
life that will just grow infinitely are
there configurations that are stable can
things switch on and off they started
playing around with gliders once people
started using computers to model as
stuff they found all sorts of amazing
configurations all generated from these
same three rules this entire fleet of
what we call spaceships these wonderful
bizarre shapes that just crawl across
this mathematical space in the mid 70s
gospel and his team discovered something
really cool they were playing around
with this idea of gliders and they
created the first thing what we call a
glider gun now the glider gun is a
stable configuration and every 27
generations
it gives birth to another glider and
then repeats itself and it keeps going
round and round and round firing the
stream of gliders across the grid they
discovered another pattern which is a
thing called the eater
this thing will consume gliders without
destroying itself in the process now on
the one hand this is very cool and very
pretty on the other hand we've
discovered a way to generate signals and
a way to destroy signals we've created
truth and false one and zero yes and no
off and on and if we have 1 and 0 we
have binary logic right the question is
can you use the game of life to actually
build circuits so have a look at this
this is an and gate here are two inputs
a and B and this down here is a and
this is our output now what do they do
by switching these little eater
configurations on and off we're gonna
get rid of that one and now a is true
one of our inputs is true but our output
still false we're gonna switch on B now
B is true but when the pattern
stabilizes our output is still false if
we turn both of those inputs now to be
true by removing both of those blockers
and we run our circuit again we've
created a logic gate we've implemented a
NAND gate within the game of life and if
we can build logic gates we can build
circuits and if we can build circuits we
can build computers and if we can build
computers we can run programs on them
including this program that you might
recently have heard about it's a thing
called Conway's Game of Life and it's a
simple cellular automaton based on these
three very very simple rules that can
lead to the most fascinatingly complex
behavior and patterns just from those
three simple rules
now Conway's Game of Life is one of a
whole category of systems that start
with very very simple rules and go on to
exhibit incredibly complex behavior
you've probably heard of something
called the butterfly effect this idea
that long-range weather forecasting is
impossible because of her butterfly
flaps its wings in Beijing next week
we're gonna have hurricanes in Los
Angeles instead of sunshine and all of
this is to do with the study of systems
that have simple inputs and complex
outputs very sensitive dependencies on
initial conditions the study of these
kinds of systems has become known as
chaos theory and it has all sorts of
applications people use chaos theory to
study stock market prices economics
weather forecasting engineering but it's
also given rise to a whole new field of
digital computerized art now to
understand what we call fractals and
fractal geometry you've got to get your
head around some really weird maths so
here's a piece of graph paper and we're
gonna draw a square here which is 2x2
and you want to tell me what the area of
that square is for now we're gonna draw
another square this one is minus 2 by
minus 2 what's the area of that square 4
so if 2 times 2 is 4 and minus 2 times
minus 2 is 4 how can we get a square
whose area is minus 4
well we can't it's completely impossible
and at this point physics and
engineering goes well yes impossible
let's get on with everything but
mathematicians go well hang on what if
it was possible what if we just make
something up what if we say all right we
accept that it doesn't exist so we're
gonna take the impossible thing we're
gonna scribble on our chalkboards here
and we're gonna come up with this number
I which we're gonna call I for imaginary
because it's not real and it doesn't
exist and it can't exist and we proved
it can't exist so let's play with it
anyway because hey mathematics and this
is the rule we say I is the number that
if you multiply it by itself you get
minus 1 everyone goes that's impossible
and we go yes maths we don't care
impossible as we did that before
breakfast
now when you take these what we call
imaginary numbers and you mix them up a
little bit with real numbers you get
what we call complex numbers
now a complex number is like a project
plan some of it is real some of it is
imaginary and you have no idea what is
gonna happen next but we can do
arithmetic with these numbers just by
following the rules so we take this
number here this is no point 8 of real
stuff and 1.2 of imaginary stuff and we
can plot this on this graph here it's a
thing called an Argand diagram and we
can actually do equations with these so
let's say we take this number point
eight plus one point two I and we want
to just multiply this number by itself
and see what we get now I've syntax I've
color-coded the numbers here
the real parts are red the imaginary
parts of blue and this is basically
highschool arithmetic with with
imaginary stuff in it we're just going
to expand that out and we can multiply
all these terms together and all you
remember is anytime two blue numbers get
multiplied you take the eyes off and the
whole thing becomes positive negative
negative square root of negative numbers
and so you expand the thing out and then
you can go through you can simplify it
back down you add the red bits together
add the blue bits together and you get
an answer at the other end the
arithmetic is not that complicated now
for most of history mathematics has been
obsessed with solving problems if you
can't solve a problem it's not
interesting but during the last century
and particularly the last decade or so a
group of scientists and mathematicians
started studying systems where they
weren't interested in solving it they
were interested in seeing how it behaved
take a function here we're gonna take
some number X and every time we're just
gonna do X maps onto X plus 1 so we
start at 0 and we go to 1 & 2 & 3 and
you can see almost immediately how this
is gonna behave this is really gonna
keep counting up to infinity right let's
take another one X goes to 2 minus X so
we're gonna start off here with 2 minus
0 is 2 2 minus 2 0 2 minus 0 is 2 so
within 2 or 3 generations we're
confident we just have this stable
looping repeating cycle
we understand the behavior of the system
and we can predict what it's gonna do
200 generations from now let's try the
same thing with a complex number so
we're gonna take this number here 0.7
plus 0.8 I and we're just gonna square
it and the first time we square it it
goes to there and we square it again and
it goes to here and then it goes to here
and then it goes to here and then it
goes flying off into by the way there
are four different flavors of infinity
on this graph so we've got the imaginary
positive infinity the imaginary negative
infinity and then we've got real
positive and negative infinity but
that's fine don't worry about it we're
not gonna go there
yeah let's move that point ever so
slightly and run the same procedure over
and over again now this time it's gonna
jump to here and then here and then here
and then here and then here and then
there now the previous one it vanished
by this point it gone off to infinity is
never coming back this one kind of
bounces around for a little while then
it does this it goes into this sort of
weird almost like a circular pattern for
a couple of generations we cannot
predict what its gonna do next and if we
take a bunch of points that are almost
next to each other and we plot in
different colors their eventual behavior
we get radically different behavior from
starting points that are almost next to
one another in this scenario the blue
line that pale blue on here does one two
three and then it goes vanishing off to
positive infinity the green one here
goes disappearing off the bottom and
then at some point it comes back in on
the top and goes has another go around
the red one is the loop we just looked
at now a pair of French mathematicians
around 1910 started studying these kinds
of shapes the iteration of complex
systems and they won a medal for it
Gaston Julia and Pierre fatou were their
names and Julia want a medal for the
work they did on that but they had to do
everything by hand during one of these
lines could take them a couple of hours
using you know graph paper and pencils
and stuff so they never really
understood what it was that they had
discovered we didn't discover that until
this guy comes along sky called Benoit
Mandelbrot he was a Polish mathematician
his family lived in France then he moved
to the US
swear he did most of his work he had an
awesome job he worked for IBM so he had
access to computers at a time when most
of the world had never seen a computer
and when he got bored he'd go to Harvard
and he'd teach mathematics for a
semester and then he'd go back to IBM
with all these new ideas and he was
fascinated by the mathematics of reality
he had this quote which kind of
summarizes his philosophy clouds are not
spheres mountains or not cones
coastlines are not circles bark is not
smooth nor does lightning travel in a
straight line he looked at the
jaggedness and the fractured nature of
the shapes that are all around us and he
wanted to understand the mathematics
that made those kinds of shapes possible
now his name has gone down in history
because of something that he discovered
using Julia and Fatt whose work on
complex systems and ibm's computers in
the late 1970's and his idea let's start
with this this complex grid of numbers
and we're going to take some starting
point here and all we're gonna do is win
a square it and then add the number we
started with and square it and add the
number we started with and we're gonna
go round and round and round and round
with that now his approach here was
we're going to run this a bunch of times
say a hundred times and if that number
disappears off to infinity and it's not
coming back then we leave it blank and
if after a hundred iterations it's still
on our grid then now we didn't he didn't
really have graphical capabilities so
what he said was well we'll just plot an
asterisk there on a line printer to give
us some idea which of these points in
our grid are still gonna belong to the
set and which ones are gonna disappear
and sometime in 1980 he and his team
became the first people ever to see this
this is a photograph of the original
rendition of the Mandelbrot set now
computers got better they got faster we
invented graphics we invented colors and
the standard algorithm that some of you
here may have played around with is you
take the same approach Z goes to Z
squared plus said you go round and round
and round and just depending how fast it
disappears you color it in in different
colors
if it goes vanishing off to infinity
really really quickly it's blue if it
takes a little while to get there it's
purple if it's really slow to get there
it's red and if it never disappears you
color it in black that's the basic
algorithm that we use to draw the
Mandelbrot set now the first time I ever
did this was on a 286 PC and I had to
start it running go to school and when I
came back and it kind of drawn this
level of detail but we have better
computers now which means we can see it
in this level of detail now the
astonishing thing about this set that
one equation Z goes to Z squared plus Z
contains a literally infinite level of
detail we're gonna start here this is
the Mandelbrot set how BIG's that screen
to 3 meters across do you reckon so
let's say that now we're at 1 times
magnification and we're gonna keep
zooming in and in and in and and when we
get to about here the original set we
started with is probably the size of the
radisson hotel and there's still all
this detail to zoom in to get a little
bigger by the time we get to a bat here
the set we started with is the size of
Vilnius and we have more detail and we
keep zooming in and we get to around
about here the original one is now
bigger than Lithuania and we have more
detail around the bat now it's probably
bigger than Europe sometime around now
the original one is probably the size of
the solar system it just keeps growing
now we're stopping here not because
we've run out of detail there's an
infinity of detail at every single one
of these tiny little points and that
original graph is now so big that if we
start here in a 747 and fly towards the
edge it's going to take us a thousand
billion years to get there and all of
this complexity came out of Z is Z
squared plus Z but there's more to it
than that
I think because this this thing the
Mandelbrot set somebody has called it
the thumbprint of God now I'm not a
spiritual man at all but I do play a lot
of computer games and I like that thing
you get in a game where you go off and
you do
I'm crazy that you're not sure whether
it's part of the quest or not and you
find something there that was put there
that says you're on the right track we
left this here for you to find it and
for us to see this first of all we had
to invent mathematics then we had to
invent imaginary numbers and work out
how to do equations with them we had to
invent computers which is basically
putting lightning inside a rock until it
learns how to think we had to come up
with these algorithms we had to build
the rendering systems to do it and we
did all that and we found this hidden
there and I think that is really cool
now computer graphics is not actually
that big a deal anymore 1982 Disney came
out with the movie Tron which Tron was
disqualified from the Academy Awards for
cheating because they said you couldn't
use computers to make films it wasn't in
keeping with the spirit of special
effects that's right they gave it a
Lifetime Achievement Award later they
sort of saw the error of their ways but
you know computer-generated imagery now
luxo jr. 1985-86 was the first fully
computer animated film we had Jurassic
Park which were the first computer
animated characters interacting
alongside human actors a few years ago
this guy appeared on our screens and if
you want to argue is this the actor
Peter Cushing who's dead or the
fictional character grand moff tarkin
who's not dead well Lucas films lawyers
would be very very happy to talk to you
but we have computers now that can
recreate just about anything we can
bring anything we can imagine to life we
can say you know hey Siri what would it
look like if friends was remade with
Nicolas Cage playing all the parts and
computers just go in and do it now like
yeah we can do that that's fine
now the reason we can do stuff like that
is because we have created computers
that can learn computers that can
recognize shapes computers that can see
things now you lie on your back in a
field on a sunny day and you're watching
the clouds you know is a cat that one
looks like a rabbit no one looks like an
airplane and your brain is seeing all of
these shapes they're not really they're
they're just clouds of vapor floating
through the sky and we've started
training computers to work in a similar
way we've built something called a
convolutional neural network and what it
does we don't really know how they work
but what we know is if you feed enough
photos of say cats and dogs through the
whole thing you end up with a network
that knows how to recognize cats and
dogs and within certain you know problem
spaces they actually work pretty well
now you might think well hey you know
how hard can it be
to tell the difference between a puppy
and a muffin well it's often harder than
you think you know but we've built very
very sophisticated dog detectors into
our computers that can look at this and
be like is that a nose or a blueberry
hang on let me look at my nose database
and stuff so we've basically built
digital dog detectors now the fun
happens if you take your dog detector
and you reverse the polarity and you say
right you're a dog amplifier now and you
give it a picture and the computer says
there's no dogs in this picture and you
go I don't care find the dogs and when
you find them enhance the dogs and a
computer goes this is a horrible idea
but all right you're the human here and
you go enhance and it comes out with
these really weird psychedelic images
now this kind of category of art is
called deep dreaming deep dream was the
first program at - three years ago came
out of Google that allowed us to do this
and stuff like this it's unsettling to
look at isn't it because you're looking
at it and what's happening is that some
parts of your brain is going dog dog dog
dog and then you look closer like that's
not a dog I don't know what that is but
I don't like it
what
is dog not a dog I honestly and because
it's exploiting the same kind of pattern
recognition things that exist in our
brains in an in the neural networks and
thanks to that we've got this entire new
category of art that never existed until
someone when what if we turned the dog
detector backwards and start inventing
dogs where there were no dogs to begin
with now I think computers and
technology are gonna do astonishing
things for the whole field of art
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a demo of a thing come out of
Google called tilt brush which is
basically or meant augmented reality
painting in 3d and I think computers
technology augmented reality virtual
reality some people are gonna use it to
do brilliant things some people are
gonna do it to you do not so brilliant
things some people are just gotta see
what they can make it do for the thrill
of going look the computer did what I
want isn't that cool
but I want to move on now let's stop
talking about using computers to make
art and I want to talk about programming
as an art in itself what if the code was
an art form now this is Donald Knuth's
famous the art of computer programming
and we have these ongoing debates what
is programming is that is it art is it
creative are their software factories
are we engineers you know what kind of
thing is it and I'm sure some of you
have reviewed code that maybe somebody
on your team wrote late at night when
they were tired and you've looked at
that code and you've gone this is not
art it's not engineering I wouldn't call
it craft in fact I don't know what I'd
call it but the good news is there is a
safe outlet a safe space for that kind
of code and it is obfuscated coding
competitions these are the goals of the
International obfuscated C code contest
to write the most obscure program to
show the importance of programming style
in an ironic way to stress compilers
with unusual code to illustrate the
subtleties of the C language and to
provide a safe forum for poor C code
here is a submission from 2015 this is
the entire source code for this program
anyone want to review this code tell me
what it does let's run it because what
the hell why read when you can just
compile and hope it's not a virus hey oh
there it is look at that it's flappy
bird in ASCII on a terminal and even on
a terminal it is still impossibly
difficult let's have a look at another
one so this
is another C source code submission um
this is just a subset of it if I show
you the whole thing it'll give the game
away a little bit but if you zoom out so
this is a Mandelbrot set generator that
runs in a UNIX terminal but it is the
Mandelbrot set generator that is shaped
like a Mandelbrot set and this won an
award now one of the things about the
obfuscated code competition is they try
and keep the program small what can you
accomplish in a like really small number
of bytes this is 32 lines of JavaScript
this if you copy and paste this and open
it up in a web browser it plays chess
and I don't mean it draws a chess board
I mean it plays chess it beats me at
chess it is an entire chess engine
implemented in that much JavaScript
including the graphics the board the
rendering and all the logic of the game
algorithm itself it's called nano chess
by a guy called Oscar Toledo G who just
keeps winning these programming
competitions he's absolutely brilliant
now in 1994 similar syncovich won an
honorable mention in the obfuscated C
contest for this program because he
submitted it with instructions saying if
you compile it using this specific
compiler it will print its own source
code because the compiler he was using
had a feature where if you gave it the
empty input this is a blank file if you
gave it empty input it would give you a
C code C program that didn't print
anything now he got an honorable mention
and they changed the rules and they said
your program must be at least one
character long otherwise it's just a
copy of this one and that one already
won which i think is fair you know but
this gets us onto this this whole field
of things called Queens now a coin is a
computer program that prints its own
source Queens some of you may have come
across in this book girdle Escher and
Bach the eternal golden braid by Douglas
Hofstadter and he's in this book
discusses a philosopher William ohm and
von Quine an American philosopher who
studied statements that refer to
themselves
and so we're gonna take this we're gonna
spin it into software how hard can it be
to write a program that prints its own
source code and you're not allowed to
read the source from disk that's
cheating you have to actually print it
so we're gonna do one now we're gonna
we're gonna build a coin right here in
c-sharp so I'm gonna start with this
this class program and I'm gonna write
line program and I'm gonna close my
brackets down here and static void main
I'm gonna close down here but now hang
on because I need to console right line
the class program but and and now I hang
on so this I need to console the console
that write the console and you very
rapidly get tangled up in your logic now
most languages have quirks that you can
exploit to get them to print their own
source code in C sure they're NC sure
got net developers in the room good
check this out what we can do is we can
put the syntax of our program into a
format string and then we can feed that
format string into itself as the thing
that should be printed where we've put
these placeholders and we have a c-sharp
program that prints its own source code
in JavaScript this kind of thing is
stupidly easy we just say function f
prints f2 string if you're using ECMO
script six this is a valid Quine now
somebody told me this and I was like I
do not believe you so I tried it and you
put that in and you press GO and sure
enough that function evaluates itself
and prints its own source code and then
I found something I think is really
brilliant which is an HTML Quine glycol
DeLeon BAM break came up with this idea
it's a web page that prints its own
source so we're gonna start with this
HTML head title blah blah blah blah blah
slash HTML and when we open this in a
browser it looks like this
now we're gonna exploit some quirks of
the HTML specification here first of all
we're going to put in a CSS rule that
says display everything as a block even
style and head and title and things that
the browser is not supposed to display
and we're gonna refresh it and look at
that our CSS and our title are now
appearing in the page code and the page
rendered output
now we're going to start exploiting some
more CSS rules we're gonna say well the
HTML element before one of those put
this content and after it put this
content and we refresh again and there
we go we've grazed him on our slash HTML
is actually here because it doesn't know
where to draw it but it is there and if
you could scroll down on the screen
you'd see it now to put style around the
style sheets we need to escape the slash
style
otherwise the parsers have a fight over
who gets dibs on that bit and the HTML
parser wins in the CSS break so we
escape that that passes that through
we're gonna put some white space
formatting on there we refresh that page
again we go round a couple of times
because we need to define rules for each
of these different elements and round
and round and round we go now we've got
this link here this a and that needs to
show the href that that a actually links
to so we can go in and see we say well
before one of these please extract the
attribute value and put that in the
content and put that into the page and
there we go a href equals yada yada yada
and I'm just going to put in one more
little rule I'm going to put a 1% height
and a margin on the HTML and there we go
slash HTML at the bottom we have a web
page that prints its own source code
beautiful and completely useless but how
much did you learn about the CSS
preprocessor that you didn't know until
you tried to do that because I learned a
hell of a lot doing that here is a
computer program what language is this
program written in C++ well I don't
let's try it I'm gonna apply some syntax
highlighting okay so I'm gonna apply a
syntax highlight here so we gonna
include standard IOH
there's main char star this is a big
string literal and then a printf yeah
alright C C++ probably works on both I
don't apply different syntax highlighter
and an apply Ruby syntax highlighter and
I'm gonna highlight the things that Ruby
thinks the string literals and that's
interesting because Ruby thinks this is
a valid Ruby program so which is it I
tell you what let's try running it so
here's our poly Quincy source code there
it is now I'm gonna feed that into GCC
and I'm gonna run it we got a warning
but hey the safety is off well before
this point kids and look at that we run
it ADA out and there we go this is our
output from that program and now I'm
gonna feed the output of that program
into Ruby and see what route oh look
there it is it's printed itself again
and now just for the hell of it I'm
gonna run the same thing in Python
that's interesting because pythons
basically Ruby anyway right
and I'm gonna run it in Perl because I
had to install Perl on my laptop just to
make this demo work and it produces the
same thing again this is what's called a
poly Quine it's a program that is valid
in more than one language and prints its
own source code in all of them and this
example runs in C Ruby pearl Python and
C++ if you can find an old enough
compiler because it complains about main
not having a return type but we can do a
hell of a lot more take a look at this
chunk of code here now
you're looking at this trying to figure
out what language it's in it's like well
we got a system console here and so
that's probably dotnet or you know C C
sharp something like that but this is an
xml XSL transform namespace so i don't
know what's going on there this is a for
each in a console dot log which kind of
smells a bit JavaScript C to me and this
is a dot txt IO procedure which I'm
guessing is is a DES I'm not familiar
with it but I did look it up and then
you know over here we've got begin in
block capitals which means it's probably
COBOL right any COBOL programmers in the
room and then up here we've got act 1
scene 1 enter Ajax which doesn't look
like programming at all this is your
Sookie and O's or abhira Squier it is a
computer program written in Ruby that
produces a program in rust which
produces a program in scala scheme said
Shakespeare s Lang small talks were all
the way around and eventually you get an
RC program that produces a Rex program
that produces the original ruby program
back again the source code to this
program
is absolutely stunning look at this
that's it with all this stuff at the
bottom where it says buffer for future
bug fixes so that they can maintain the
exact shape of it and you know the most
brilliant thing about this all 128 of
those languages you can apt-get install
on Ubuntu Linux and so there is a
continuous integration pipe for this
program on github that will run all of
those programs and just contrast the
time we started a little late so we're
gonna overrun by a few minutes there's a
break straight after this right yeah
yeah cool all right
otherwise I'd have to skip the good bits
and I don't want all you to miss out now
in this coin you notice among the COBOL
and everything there was this weird Act
one Scene one and two Ajax you know
what's going on there well it turns out
there is a programming language called
Shakespeare which is designed for making
programs that read like Shakespeare
plays and the way Shakespeare works is
that flattering things increment
variables and insulting things decrement
variables and so here is the infamous
hello world program first of all we have
to declare our variables by introducing
them so we have Romeo a young man with a
remarkable patience and Hamlet the
flatterer of Anderson insulting a s act
one Hamlet's insults and flattery scene
one enter Hamlet and Romeo Hamlet says
you lying stupid fatherless big smelly
half-witted coward you are as stupid as
the difference between a handsome rich
brave hero and theyself speak your mind
that will print H you are as brave as
the sum of your fat little stuffed
misused dusty old rotten codpiece and a
beautiful fair warm peaceful sunny
summer's day you are as healthy as the
difference between the sum of the
sweetest reddest rose and my father and
yourself speak your mind
E speak your mind speak your mind
l l and then this final line here is O
so this this little thing here prints
the hallo in hello world now I like this
because Shakespeare plays were not noted
for being short
and neither are Shakespeare programmes
and Shakespeare's a lovely example of
what we call esoteric languages Easter
lands which are computer programs where
the entire programming language is
designed to be funny and beautiful and
useless here is hallo world anyone know
what language this is written in this is
white space a language that ignores
everything except spaces and tabs here
is syntax highlighting for hello world
in what space white space is a brilliant
language for hiding programs inside
other programs because you can put the
spaces and tabs in a C program and the C
compiler will ignore them and white
space will ignore all the C code so you
can write coins in white space really
easily this is the hello world souffle
in the programming language called chef
now chef is designed for writing
programs that are also recipes and the
canonical hello world involves 72 grams
of beans 101 eggs a hundred and eleven
cups of oil a hundred grams of mustard
and 33 potatoes now this prints hello
world when you run it in chef but it
doesn't look like a terribly appetizing
recipe and a few years ago a guy called
Mike worth created a recipe a hello
world in chef that is also actually a
cake and he baked it and you know I love
this because he killed this video of
this thing is a valid set of
instructions in two completely
disconnected domains if you run it in
the chef interpreter it prints hello
world and if you run it in your kitchen
you get a chocolate cake with chocolate
sauce that apparently was a little dry
but really quite good and I love this
idea of computer programs that also
exist entirely independently as art in
their own right let's have a look at how
to square a number in the programming
language called Pete there it is that's
the program
is a graphical programming language this
is the instruction set
every time the cursor the cursor starts
here and it moves across this grid and
when it travels between two colors that
is an instruction from this set here
variations in hue and variations in
lightness this is our color palette
light normal and dark and let's look at
how that example actually works so we
start there and when we cross from light
blue to dark green that's a difference
of two in the but the brightness four in
the hue input a number reads some input
black means change direction dark green
to dark red duplicate whatever's on the
stack two of those dark red into yellow
take the two numbers off the top of the
stack multiply them and push that back
onto the stack yellow into dark red
output whatever's on the stack so we've
squared these numbers now we print the
output anything that crosses white is a
no op no operation when we get to the
edge of the grid here we change
direction we keep moving inside this
blue thing and so we end up with black
on all sides and that means halt the
program is finished this is hello world
in Pete and it's also just nice it's
artistic it's the kind of thing you
could hang on a wall and nobody would
ever know that you were looking at a
computer program I like that idea now
we've talked a lot about this idea of
you know programs that you give to
somebody and they run it later and it
does something and we've talked about
designing languages and publishing them
online but you know have this idea in
software that everything needs to be
reproducible right we automate
everything unit tests integration tests
delivery pipelines take the humans out
of the loop because they might not do
the same thing twice and when you watch
live performance anything can happen now
I'm sure there are gonna be people here
at build stuff who are gonna do live
coding demos and life coding demos are
kind of exciting right because anything
can happen it might work it might not
work
you might what was it you did mark
exceeded the rate limit on the people
issuing the certificates for your demo
because you rehearsed it so many times
you burned out their quota
and use the last one life performance
has this excitement in this risk and in
computing we talk about things that are
hard to reproduce as snowflakes right we
talk about snowflakes servers don't
patch it don't run Windows Update if you
even breathe on it all the finance
system will stop working
we've tried putting it in the cloud and
the cloud broke and now we just locked
it in a room and never touch it ever
again but also if you pick a snowflake
out of a blizzard and you watch it melt
on your hand you've just seen something
nobody else will ever see you are part
of this unique experience that will
never happen again and that's what makes
live performance exciting this guy here
is Sam Aaron Sam created a programming
language called sonic Pi which is
optimized for doing live performance and
I want to give you a very quick
run-through of sonic PI now you learn
sonic PI and you do play a four and it
plays a mint now sonic PI is the only
language in the world where everything
runs in parallel unless you tell it not
to imagine if JavaScript ran all your
statements at the same time unless you
put pauses in we're going to go in here
we're going to say use bpm that's beats
per minute and we're gonna put a couple
of notes in here and we're gonna put in
a loop we're gonna say 16 times do this
and we've got a beat
and now we're gonna go and we're gonna
start plugging in a little bit of logic
we're gonna put in this variable I and
we're gonna say is I divisible by three
if it is play this note otherwise play
that note and then increment I I is I
plus 1 and we've just invented
electronic music go us well done it was
much harder when they had to do this
with analog like being able to do it on
a Raspberry Pi makes everything much
easier but what makes sonic PI amazing
is something called life loops so we've
defined a live loop here we've called it
my loop and we've said just keep doing
that over and over and over and now
while that's still running we're gonna
drop him down here and we're gonna
create another loop which we're gonna
call symbols and in this loop we're
going to play some samples drum sounds
now first of all this line here sync to
my loop it says these loops always start
at the same time keep them in sync deep
to the beat and we're gonna say three
times play the sample drum symbol closed
you'll hear what that sounds like in a
second and then we're gonna drop in
actually would do that 15 change that
round because we got 16 beats in this
bar we're gonna play a drum symbol open
just to close it out and then without
stopping anything now you hear that
dropped in in the background now it's
doing all of this in real time it's
optimized for live performance if you've
worked on real time AP is you can live
with 30 40 milliseconds of latency
that's pretty good right even for like
first-person shooters in music 40
milliseconds will kill you because
everything sounds horrible it sounds
like country music so we need to keep it
absolutely tightly focused so underneath
this sonic pie interpreter there is a
thing called super collider which is a
real-time audio engine which is based on
Erlang which means it can patch methods
and functions while the program is
running and have the old the current in
the new version in memory simultaneously
so we can do things like write a drum
pattern while that melody is still
playing we can come over here we can
drop that loop in
we can fix the name error there it is
you ready
and now we're gonna come back to our
little melody here and we're gonna say
well if that number is divisible by five
I want you to play this note and if it's
divisible by three I want you to play
this note and if it's divisible by 15
[Music]
does anyone recognize the algorithm
that's being implemented here a
venerable screening process for
recruiting developers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what we've got here is fist buzzers
implemented in music and we're gonna put
a little bit of reverb and we're gonna
change some of the effects around a
little bit just to make it sound a
little bit more exciting not that we get
a huge amount through the projector
speaker that's up there but
[Music]
so that's sonic pipe real-time
interactive audio programming now I want
to finish up we have a few minutes left
by telling you about the thing that I
did because all this stuff about Easter
Taric languages and climbs and all that
kind of stuff it gave me an idea you see
we've always had this trope about this
idea of the Rockstar developer right you
look at the ads on LinkedIn and you'll
see everyone is out there recruiting for
rock stars rock stars do this rock
started do that rock started do that and
last year
pulsed eval put this on Twitter he said
to really confuse recruiters someone
should make a programming language
called rock star and I had this
experience I had this moment of blinding
revelation because you see when I wasn't
messing around with logo on amstrad's
I was listening to music like this and I
thought this is what the world needs the
world needs a curing complete
programming language for writing
computer programs that are also 1980s
hard rock power ballads
so the hello world in rock star is very
easy as say hello world but it's also
scream or whisper or shout because
creative expression is what Rockstar is
all about variables an assignment now we
have in X and we have var my string and
we have the message and this does not
look terribly rock and roll now first of
all we don't need semicolons we don't
need types it's a dynamically typed
language if this is good enough for Ruby
it's good enough for rock star now we
don't want these equal signs we're gonna
plug in is instead how many of you ever
had an argument longer than three hours
about whether they use Pascal case or
camel case or chainsaw case or snake
case or any of these other cases because
I saw Douglas Crockford give a talk last
year when he said we have all these
stupid arguments when what we really
want are variable names with spaces in
them now I invented rock star in a bar
and when you invent programming
languages in a bar you can do anything
you want so we can have variables with
spaces in them there are simple
variables we have common variables my
heart your dream the night dr. feelgood
Black Betty Billie Jean anything
starting with capitals you can chain
those together less of
variablename now programming involves a
lot of numbers and rock-and-roll kind of
dozen fizzes three buzzes five the limit
is 100
I wanted a more creative way of
initializing variables so I came up with
this what if we take the lengths of the
words modulo 10 and treat those as
digits in a number so we've got 3 5 1 0
0 the limit is a love-struck Ladykiller
that's much more creative than limit
equals 100 isn't it we can do with
floating-point numbers as well you want
to initialize pi and c 3.1415 them and
JavaScript via pi equals but it's
JavaScript so you're gonna get almost 2
pi like approximately in rock star my
heart was ice a life unfulfilled waking
everybody up taking booze and pills
3.1415 we needed arithmetic now in
English we talk about are how much is
that it's the price with the tax it's
the total without the tax the quantity
of the product the distance over the
time here's the same thing in rock star
but we can be more creative we can say a
girl with a dream a man without a face
the wings of the night a whisper over
the water we need comparison your love
is a lie the whiskey ain't the answer my
heart is stronger than steel my soul is
weaker than water my will is as strong
as a lion and your lies are as low as a
snake you can't program with that
functions right so modulus takes a
number and a divisor and while a number
is as high as a divisor put a number
without a divisor into a number and give
back a number this blank line by the way
that terminates the loop because that's
how music works
we don't need semicolons and n
statements it's a blank line it means
something just finished alternatively
midnight takes your heart and your soul
and while your heart is as high as your
soul put your heart without your soul
into your heart and give back your heart
so I did this and I came up with this
parody language specification I stuck it
on github and I tweeted about it and the
internet went kind of crazy and it made
the front page of hacker news it got a
write-up in boeing-boeing magazine
people on reddit were saying nice things
I don't if you hang out and read it but
getting reddit to say nice things is no
small achievement it doesn't happen very
often shut up and take my money then
this happened
classic rock is a real rock magazine
that has nothing to do with programming
jokes and they emailed me and said
what's this rock star thing we keep
hearing about and they did a feature on
it alongside interviews with the Rolling
Stones and the tiger people like that
dislike then people started filing
issues and I was like why are you filing
an issue and they said because your
specification has undefined behavior and
I said why do you care and they said
because my compiler has undefined
behavior and I said what
and they said I've implemented a Rasta
compiler in Scala yesterday I was like
you can do that and it just kept going
round and round around there's about
five different implementations suddenly
sprung up there's a Scala one and a rust
one and a Python transpiler and all
kinds of things and you know I kind of I
like the sound of Dylan Beatty the
creator of Rockstar but I didn't think
that just writing a parody spec in a bar
was enough work to justify it so I
decided it I actually had to build an
interpreter for it if I was gonna do
this and I did it over Christmas in
JavaScript because I'm an idiot and for
another reason II because I wanted
everybody to be able to run Rockstar
without installing in the Rockstar to be
a language you can write in a browser on
your phone so that everybody can become
a certified Rockstar developer
and so I did code with Rockstar comm
slash online there is an interpreter
there anybody here can type in some code
run it and come up and get your official
certified Rockstar developer
certificates which are self-adhesive and
wipe clean by the way the logo here
that's on the website I just want a
little tip of the hat to the people I
stole that from because they weren't
using it anymore I wanted something that
was really like all out over the top 80s
neon rock and roll and I looked at lots
of band logos I didn't come up with
anything then somebody said have you
considered Microsoft consumer products
1980 to 1982 and I went yes I'm gonna
recycle that so thank you Microsoft so
that is the story of Rockstar now I'd
like your help with something
because I have one little surprise left
in store for you today this morning and
that is the example of the chocolate
cake that was also a valid program in
chef I want to see if we can have a rock
star program that's also a valid song
and so what I'm going to do is to
perform it for you
fizzbuzz live at build stuff and you can
draw your own conclusions as to whether
you think this is two kinds of art
one kind of art or no kind of art at all
that alright with you
[Applause]
[Music]
I've just worked out what the problem is
lalalalalalalala there will be a tiny
tiny interlude while we do that
[Music]
takes your heart and your soup while
your heart is as high as your sue
put your heart without your soul into
your heart
give back your heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
virus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you build stuff
[Applause]